your taxi this is a friend of yours who
was staying with you last night yeah
yeah
um can you just describe what happened
last last night well we were talking
with each other you see we're just in
the house
now and suddenly
um I heard is shouting and noising you
know everywhere and then uh the
youngster was shouting you know like
verbally abusing you know so but
honestly it was terrible I've never ever
seen like that situation in my lifetime
it's really terrible but Angel people
maybe and it was just ridiculous
there's just like I meant to be in work
right now and I can't go because I've
had no sleep people's beans were being
stolen a little fire
I stuck my mama Back Garden to mind and
get stolen that's when Eva's car
so I didn't get smashed in people have
lost their lives during this so
Mike has nothing when
two people have suddenly passed away so